the girag an experience I I have so many
memories of not even playing there just
going to Hollywood I used to go watch
bands I used to go watch van Halen play
I used to go just hang out you know and
that sort of half the fun of the rainbow
is just being there and seeing all the
freaks and all the cool people and all
the you know the people like well
there's that guy there's Lemmy from
Motorhead there's all these strange
characters and rockers and all these
people that have been around Hollywood
forever I don't really know why you know
it's just happy you know it's right next
to the Roxy it's just uh just want a
spot it's one of those putts or people
just get a good vibe there or something
you know that strip is just the Sunset
Strip is just one of the all-time
classic spots in Americana
I mean just really is where the Comedy
Store is the Viper Room is it's
incredible and whiskey the history of
going back to even like days of the
doors I mean our you know just to know
that they played the Troubadour or even
you know early days with like Linda
Ronstadt her backup band was was like
Don Henley and and Glenn Frey you know
that was their backup in and they went
off and made the Eagles or whatever yes
incredible so yeah it's it's not you
know the history it goes way beyond the
the 70s and the 80s it's like goes back
to the 60s and you know I mean you've
got the doors look at how big that
Bandit you know they're the type man
like that you you don't think of them
doing regular guy stuff like they're
there to me you know you know when
you're a kid and you think of a band and
you like I know they don't drive through
McDonald's like we do it's like right
you think like they're almost alien door
so that you don't even wasn't that the
the mystique of that been sort of eroded
by the internet like there was a thing
the other day where Charlie Sheen was
having a Twitter beef with his ex-wife
right and it was that's ridiculous
ridiculous yeah but it was the that's
been that that sort of thing is
different now
Pleiades - he used to be the one a guy
was a big star that they would be sort
of living up on a house and the behind
these crazy you really didn't know what
each oh yeah like know a show you're on
the internet you're literally in two
minutes
people are watching your show you know
the show you're playing in France
they're watching it in LA and you just
got done with the show like two minutes
ago well then they get to read your
Twitter pages when I was a kid when I
was again a kid it would literally be
this much of an event it would last all
day I'd go by like Robin Trower record
going to my friends you know we'd set up
everything man get two speakers outside
the window and listen to this album over
and over and over now kids download 300
songs in 20 minutes before they go to
school or in their iPod or whatever it's
just not it's not as personal as it used
to be you know like it's more accessible
it's more accessible it's uh you know I
asked Rosen comrade the article with
David girl or whatever from Foo Fighters
yeah Foo Fighters and Nirvana and he
makes so much sense to me because I I
went through all these things that he's
talking about which is playing with guys
that don't really play that good and
we're jamming in the garage and you know
pissing off my parents and you know and
just going through that and improving
from there and just getting better you
know whatever instead of people just
thrown together with their songs written
by somebody else and all that you know
it's just that the sum of the human
element has been that's my only
complaint and it's not really a
complaint it's just I just prefer that
people play music and not machines you
know and I know you're saying yeah well
there's also the experience of going to
the record store and looking at the
album art and take it home and that
exactly something missing am i driving
200 miles or 150 miles to do a photo
shoot when I'm going to be the size of
an ant on you know yeah microchip
yeah but or whatever but you know I it's
not really complain my whole thing is I
just want to get our music to the people
the best way I can and I if you know
your way around the internet you can you
can get that done and we just got done
up this big monster cruise and you know
30 bands on this big ship and we went
and played on an island and you know it
was like a it was great you know so I'm
you know I'm not bitter or anything I
know things are different it's really
difficult on major labels you know
because we can go record our next Elmo
your house on your computer yeah you
know I think that puts a lot of power in
the artists hands though and also us it
also puts a lot of power in their
ability to promote themselves all they
need is the internet now exactly and all
those other closed off avenues like we
were talking about getting on the Ed
Sullivan Show was everything to a guy
like Rodney Dangerfield you couldn't get
on The Ed Sullivan Show you were fucked
today for a comic especially boy you
don't need that at all I mean my friends
who have become famous from the internet
like Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir and
Duncan Trussell they've only had the
internet the Internet is all they ever
needed but all they had to eat all they
needed was talent and an avenue in my
days I needed a staple gun in the
posters and Sunset Boulevard to get
people to come out yeah and then they'd
have to see the poster she'll be excited
by it like no rain comes by and they put
it over ours oh yeah those cars over
there the wars of posters it's still
awards yeah well there's internet wars
now you know there's there's definitely
a lot of that there's still a lot of
fuckin morons out there when it comes to
that kind of stuff but but I think it's
definitely a better time as far as
putting the power in the hands of the
artists and these people that are than
the normal cabal that we're controlling
the music industry they've they've lost
a lot of their power right oh yeah and
you know the difference now is we don't
need millions of dollars to to record
and and all that kind of promotion and
and that's why that they're the major
labels are suffering a bit and yeah the
where the power comes in is we're know
no longer are we just getting our little
points you know when they're taking you
know we make a million dollars at the
record company gets you know nine
hundred and whatever and you know they
throw our crumbs enough crumbs to where
we don't like go away but you know but
people don't realize that for most folks
they'd have no idea like how bad the
deals were yeah especially like jail was
amazingly bad and they even speak about
it on the internet you can go on and
there sit together and they're actually
interviewing each other about the old
days you know people think we're the
bitch and rock stars but we are we were
literally broke there they said that
their checks per week who this is during
the first album were eighty eight
dollars and eighty three cents or
something yeah and they were selling
millions about yeah yeah a million dates
okay here's the funny part they got off
this tour and and the record company
says you always 2 million dollars and he
goes okay let me get this straight so if
we do ten tours and sell 20 million
records we're gonna owe you 20 million
dollars doesn't that say yeah it it's
just from all the loans and that you
know the first coming out of the gate
but um well it's also just a corrupt
system it has too much power it's
corrupt in you know the being the artist
when you don't have your own
representation and you know you just
want to do anything to break out of this
club scene you know you want to be a big
ban on big tours and so you
they take bad deals you know a lot of a
lot of bands have done that you know
they've done successful with their album
sales but their business side of is
really horrid yeah yeah that's also the
difference between a businessperson and
an artist like a lot of artists are
impulsive and they're just not that good
at things like that they're not that
good isn't it and I'm one of them I you
know our deal wasn't great either and
but we've kind of made up for that we
wasn't our whole career but at the
beginning it wasn't they're great but
but Sanna it always starts off nobody
ever says aw we got an awesome deal
right out of that
eight and we're fortunate an ethical
record company no geez you talk about
the fucking scoundrels that signed you I
mean that's also you think about a music
company how many people do they sign I
mean they might sign a hundred and one
of them might become great white
you know this there's a lot of failure
involved on there and to
prognostications you know that that's
what they call their write ups you know
the write up bills but yeah yeah but for
a band that's successful the the the
reality behind it did you ever read that
piece that Courtney Love wrote on the
music business
she wrote a pretty incredible piece
about explaining the expenses and how
much it actually costs and what an
artist actually gets paid and how much
the studio gets paid and how they go
about saying how much things are worth I
haven't read the piece but I'm glad she
wrote something like that because it
will school the audience and you know
yeah it's not their business pretty
incredible stop kidding yeah well
there's a little bit of that but it's
also there are some educational you know
people will understand that you know we
work really hard and we're not just
walking around you know zillionaire sure
well you bummed out when the whole
Napster thing came along people started
downloading mp3s and it just almost
immediately sort of took the wind out of
the sails of Records um you know I was
bummed out even before that a little bit
but you know III know me like I talking
about earlier that I'm a fan of music
and I like to support the artists I go
out and buy their albums you know I I
want the artwork I want to know who
wrote the songs I want to know where
they recorded this album I you know I
just think that's part of it and that's
what makes the world go round in music
is to support the artists so I go out
and buy ZZ Top CD and you know but when
somebody comes up and go hey man I just
got your new album I copied it for my
friend it's like well thanks you know at
least he's going to maybe give me some
feedback and if you likes it or not or
hopefully he'll go see you live you know
go see us live or whatever but yeah um I
don't know man it is what I'm not gonna
say that that it is what it is yeah but
it is what it is I mean we were changing
the
world is changing around us technology's
forcing us to change and we have to
adapt but the most important thing is
you're still creating you're still doing
what you love you still doing doing and
then the commerce aspect of it has to
morph and as to morph to accommodate
this new environment that we live in but
the environment is so beneficial in so
many other ways it's it just is what it
is yeah it has to change
yeah there's no way you're not going to
have the world change when something
like the internet comes along yeah all
these other away but the bet that I
think the benefits way outweigh the
negatives in my opinion definitely and
our fans are loyal to I mean we go over
to you know Sweden or you know
Switzerland or whatever and they're all
there in front of the stage you know so
so we are blessing that way I mean you
know no matter what happens in the
industry our fans have always hung so
it's like you know well that's a little
because you guys appreciate it I'm sure
that has a lot to do with it we are
grateful for our fans and I always tell
them that and you know in the in the
days when we were you know playing
arenas every night is very difficult you
know that the constructed meet and
greets we can only meet a few and you
really can't go out and say hey you know
invite 20,000 people backstage a to put
for the party you know but we've really
taken advantage of being able to hear
their stories man I mean I'm talking
like stories that I don't remember I
mean you know people doing my laundry
and gave me a ride here or you know they
were in this certain place or this guy
got married to this song or you know it
got laid because you know that your song
this one or you know I mean it's just
the stories are endless in and how you
personally and affected these people
yeah I mean if our music is involved the
people's life on like that because I
have again I can relate because like I
was saying earlier I literally have
visuals when I hear certain songs you
know like I remember where I was how old
I was what I was doing you know almost
like the smell that was in the air
practically you know and so when people
come up and have a similar story about
me
like that that my band was involved in
it's like you have to feel like that's a
pretty tall compliment you know get you
know just be involved with that